right 6 14 is the time on this Tuesday
morning and it is National exercise day
all right it's the one day of the year
we were supposed to work out right no
one day and one of the fastest ways to
burn off all those calories you've
probably heard this before you gotta
turn up the heat turn up the intensity
yeah we know someone who turns up the
intensity on a daily basis Candice
Charles who is live this morning at true
Fusion to give a look inside Candace
good morning to you
[Music]
John I'm hoping you'll actually get out
here with me and do a little bit of
exercise but you're not just today you
guys there's so many benefits to
exercising as you can see all these
folks are in a different circuit right
now we're going to be showing you some
of the circles that happen right here in
the head class and have Aaliyah with me
right now thank you so much for joining
me tell us a little bit about the hit
clock so the hit class is a 45 minute
High interval training so five minutes
at each station and then they switch
some stations are focused on cardio some
are focused on strength building muscle
all really great full body workout
definitely what are the benefits of
spine Body Soul getting pull season
ready looking really great feeling
really great clip awesome that's the
important thing right okay we have one
of the circuits here's one yes Candace
these are our battle ropes so you're
gonna go ahead and pick it up thumbs up
that nice athletic stance and start to
snake those hands yeah more at the risk
good Candace chorus tight beautiful more
red yes and then another one here what
is this one here this is our pick it up
keep that athletic stance slam it as
hard as you can pick it back up and
continue to slam yes get all that energy
out thank you Leanne I'm feeling strong
thank you so much you guys can you come
on down here and enjoy the class they
have want to hear on the Eastern they
have multiple locations different levels
for everyone involved you can find more
details on the website newsnow.com for
now live from True Futures Alpha Eastern
of Kansas Charles hey this now